sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
ihnen allen einen schönen guten morgen
die sitzung ist eröffnet
zunächst einmal begrüße ich meine beiden
kollegen hier neben mir recht herzlich
aber vor allen dingen die kolleginnen
dann dr daniela de ridder sie ist
nämlich für die ausgeschiedene kollegin
jasmin fach chemie wieder im deutschen
bundestag eingezogen hat das mandat
angenommen herzlich willkommen im namen
des ganzen hauses
ich rufe jetzt auf die
tagesordnungspunkte
26a bis 26
beratung mehrerer vorlagen zur änderung
des bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
sowie des
berufsbildungsberichts
2022 für die aussprache wurde eine dauer
von 68 minuten vereinbart ich eröffne
die aussprache und das wort hat zuerst
für die bundesregierung die ministerin
bettina stark watzinger
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir uns
wohl in einem einig sind dann die idee
des bafög ist gut aber jedes zukunfts
instrument wird irgendwann alt wenn es
keine reformen bekommt und erreicht auch
nicht mehr alle die es erreichen sollte
die zeiten ändern sich also ändern wir
heute das bafög höhere
höhere freibeträge
machen künftig attraktiver der digitale
antrag macht es moderner die höhere
altersgrenze macht es flexibler und wir
fühlen eine weitere stufe des ausstiegs
versprechens wieder in unserem land mit
neuem leben darum geht es heute und
dafür werde ich um ihre zustimmung
wir bringen das bafög zurück in die
zukunft und passendes an die realität
des 21 jahrhunderts an wir müssen
vorankommen dringend denn bildung ist
zukunft entscheidend deshalb bin ich
froh dass wir so schnell mit der
bafög-reform sind ich bedanke mich bei
den koalitionspartnern ich bedanke mich
bei meinem haus und ich bedanke mich
auch bei meinem staatssekretär jens
brandenburg dass wir das so schnell auf
den weg gebracht haben das
ist ein sprungbrett für alle für die
dies würde sonst zu hoch wären springen
muss natürlich jeder noch selbst aber
jeder und jede soll es schaffen können
das ist die aufgabe von uns in der
politik zu ermöglichen damit alle eine
freie wahl für den eigenen bildungsweg
haben und ihn selbstständig gehen können
die bisherige förderung hat noch zu viel
an ausgeschlossen wir klären diesen
trend um mehr bafög heißt mehr freiheit
dazu
dazu gehört in unserer modernen welt
auch mal ein auslandsjahr zu machen die
eigene komfortzone zu verlassen sich in
einer anderen sprache auszutauschen
internationale kontakte zu knüpfen und
verständnis für andere kulturen zu
entwickeln sich diese wertvollen
erfahrungen leisten zu können auch das
ist eine frage der bildungsgerechtigkeit
chancengerechtigkeit und deshalb stärken
wir beim bafög auf die auslands
förderung das betrifft den zuschlag für
die studiengebühren und die ausweitung
auf einjährige masterprogramme auch
außerhalb der eu ein auslandsstudium das
ebenso wenig am geld scheitern wie ein
inland studium
die änderungen im bafög zahlen sich
übrigens auch zugunsten der beruflichen
bildung aus dem schüler-bafög und im
aufstiegs bafög es kommt beruflichen
aufsteigern zugute der sich bilden will
der soll das auch können bildungschancen
sind die höchste form von respekt die
wir jedem einzelnen in unserem land
entgegen bringen können egal auf welchem
weg und heute ist auch der
berufsbildungsbericht thema auch hier
sehen wir es gibt noch viel zu tun es
muss kein studium sein dafür heißt nicht
alle sollen studieren sondern alle
sollen studieren können und wer lieber
wer lieber eine ausbildung macht den
ermutigen wir diesen weg zu gehen die
unternehmen sie suchen nachwuchs und
zwar händeringend die auszubildenden
schon heute das sind unsere fachkräfte
von morgen und deswegen setzen wir auch
weiter auf die allianz für aus und
fortbildung sie ist ein verlässliches
bündnis zugleich bereiten wir eine
exzellenzinitiative berufliche bildung
vor denn unser duales bildungssystem ist
seit jahrzehnten garant für unseren
wohlstand und das muss auch so bleiben
akademische und berufliche bildung sich
stehen nebeneinander und das müssen wir
tief in unsere gesellschaft hinein
tragen beide systeme sind gleichwertig
beide systeme brauchen die richtigen
talente und abschlüsse beider systeme
sind gefragt ob meister oder master und
bachelor oder gesellenbrief das ist gut
so meine dank
meine damen und herren deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass alle ihre ganz persönlichen
chancen leben können und auch vor augen
haben auch das bafög viele kennen es
aber nicht alle die einen anspruch
darauf haben wissen dass auch das wollen
wir ändern indem wir die reform mit
einer zielgruppengerechten
informationskampagne begleiten und in
dem wir immer wieder deutlich machen
nachrechnen lohnt sich denn bildung
lohnt sich für uns alle ich freue mich
auf die debatte herzlichen dank
bettina stark watzinger
bundesbildungsministerin zu ja
inzwischen 27 ssten novelle des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
es soll wieder mehr interessenten und
bedürftige erreichen ob das funktioniert
und brauche ich damit beispielsweise die
union einverstanden ist mit dieser art
und weise jetzt von katrin staffel mehr
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in der vorbereitung auf die
heutige debatte habe ich mir noch mal
angesehen die
reformen die in den letzten jahren in
den letzten sechzehn unionsgeführten
jahren zum bafög gemacht worden sind
fünf grundlegende reformen war 20 drei
davon haben wir zusammen mit der spd auf
den weg gebracht zwei zusammen mit der
fdp jedesmal schritt für schritt des
bafög ein stück besser geworden für die
studierenden und hat die
bildungsgerechtigkeit in unserem land
verbessert insofern liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wenn sie heute vorhaben
genau so wie es in der letzten debatte
die wir vor ein paar wochen hier zum
bafög geführt haben
vorhaben zu behaupten dass die union in
den letzten jahren nichts für die
studierenden getan hätte ich würde ihn
vorschlagen schreiben sie reden schnell
noch mal um es ist nämlich nichts
anderes als fake news aber helfen sie
ihrem gedächtnis besser noch ein stück
auf die sprünge weil ich gut gelaunten
kann es auch positiv ausdrücken machen
sie sich doch bitte nicht kleiner als
das in
also weg von den schränken sind zu den
tatsachen die geförderten zahlen gehen
seit jahren zurück ja das ist fakt und
das gefällt uns gleichermaßen die ihnen
natürlich nicht
anders als sie aber in der ampel
regierung haben wir uns mit der frage
auseinandergesetzt warum gehen die
geförderten zahlen eigentlich zurück und
anders essen wir eben nicht der meinung
dass wir das problem einfach mit geld zu
schützen können wir müssen an die wahren
ursachen ran und da ansetzen wo wirklich
das problem liegt und was eben nicht zu
den ursachen gehört die man bekämpfen
sollten ist zb dass die eltern seit
jahren steigende löhne hatten in den
vergangenen jahren oder eben auch das
zunehmende autonomie bedürfnis der
studierenden die sich ihr studium ist ja
gerne selber finanzieren möchten und
dabei gleichzeitig auch mit
berufserfahrung sammeln ich glaube das
sind eher punkte worüber wir uns freuen
sollten und keine punkte die man
bekämpfen sollten das darf uns aber
natürlich nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
dass das bauwerk natürlich sehr wohl
dringend reformiert werden muss deshalb
adressieren wir jetzt in unseren
anträgen die wir gestellt haben die
wirklichen gründe für den rückgang der
geförderten fallen zum beispiel die
komplizierte antrag stellen und wir
haben das in der anhörung dazu gehört
auch die langen bearbeitungszeiten sind
so ein thema und aus unserer sicht soll
sich der beirat für ausbildungsförderung
mit der vereinfachung der bafög antrags
verfahren auseinandersetzen und dazu
dann auch noch die wissenschaftliche
expertise in form von evaluationen
einholen können ich glaube dass das ein
wichtiger schritt um dieses thema
voranzubringen außerdem fordern wir die
regierung auf darauf hinzuwirken dass
weitere schritte zur vereinfachung der
bafög antragstellung gemacht werden da
kann man zum beispiel die zahl der
nachweise reduzieren die gebraucht
werden eine elektronische datenaustausch
zwischen bache kämpfern auf der einen
seite und den anderen behörden auf der
anderen seite sollten wir möglich machen
und die rechtlichen grundlagen dafür für
diesen austausch die haben wir am ende
der letzten legislaturperiode
mit dem register modernisierungsgesetz
bereits gelegt das heißt die grundlagen
sind da und mit dieser grundlage können
wir jetzt von seiten des bundes aus
hinwirken dass die bearbeitung der
anträge beschleunigt werden kann
auch dabei kann es der ausbau der
digitalisierung helfen und ja ich weiß
das sind die länder natürlich in den
bergen auch federführend aber natürlich
können wir als bund auch einen
prototypen zur digitalen
antragsbearbeitung entwickeln und wir
können diesen auch test mäßig nutzen
und auch das thema regelstudienzeit muss
aus unserer unter die lupe genommen
werden dafür braucht es eine evaluation
aus unserer sicht und zwar
aufgeschlossen nach studiengängen damit
wir überhaupt mal eine statistische
grundlage haben nach der wir die
bestehende höchst forderungshöhe dauer
sachgerecht auch am ende beurteilen
können
es wäre also vieles möglich und mit dem
bafög einen weiteren schritt in die
richtung der zukunft zu machen und
leider haben sie aber im ausschuss sind
schon sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie
unsere vorschläge ablehnen und dabei hat
uns doch der 22 gericht den wir jetzt
vorliegen haben gezeigt dass wir mit der
sechsundzwanzigster modelle also der
novelle die wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode gemacht haben auf dem
richtigen weg waren weil der rückgang
mehr gefordert und geförderten zahlen
laut bericht ja sehr deutlich
zurückgegangen ist und natürlich sind
wir da noch nicht am ende des weges
angekommen deswegen müssen wir jetzt die
schritte die wir angesetzt haben
weitergehen und ich möchte zum abschluss
noch mal zurückkommen auf unsere letzte
debatte zu dieser reform vor einigen
wochen man hätte er da den eindruck
bekommen können dass wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode in gemeinsame
regierungsverantwortung mit der spd gar
nichts für die studierenden getan hätten
deshalb jetzt hier nochmal zu den fakten
im jahr 2019 als die sechsundzwanzigster
novelle in kraft getreten das lag die
inflation bei 1,4 prozent
die bedarfssätze haben wir damals um
sieben prozent erhöht im mai diesen
jahres war die inflationsrate bei 7,9
prozent und sie möchten jetzt die
bedarfssätze nein nicht wie ursprünglich
gedacht um fünf prozent erhöhen nein zu
erhöhen sogar um 5,7 5 merken sie selber
oder
so und
gehen weil der letzten rede schon gesagt
die 27 novelle des bafögs ist ein
reförmchen
sie schafft kleinere verbesserungen jahr
zugegeben sie greift aber zu kurz die
brach packt die probleme die wir mit dem
bafög haben nichts an der wurzel wir
haben konkrete vorschläge gemacht die
dazu beigetragen hätten dass man einen
größeren schritt hätten machen können um
die studenten zu unterstützen
es ist schade dass sie diese vorschläge
allesamt abgelehnt haben
schade auch deswegen weil wir natürlich
deswegen oder weil wir der meinung sind
dass das bafög den nächsten schritt zur
verbesserung
braucht und wir hätten den schritt gerne
gemeinsam mit ihnen gemacht in der
vorliegenden form der novelle sehen wir
die verbesserung aber leider nicht in
dem maße in dem sie nötig gewesen wären
dass wir müssen wir die gesetzesänderung
leider ablehnen und die anträge die dazu
gemacht waren es bleibt aber der wunsch
dass wir mit den mit der von ihnen
angekündigten strukturreform des bafög
mehr für die studierenden in deutschland
tun können vielen dank
kathrin stadler aus der unionsfraktion
präzise aus der csu landesgruppe nennt
die bafög-novelle ein reförmchen und man
hätte an der einen und anderen stelle
weitergeben können die verteidigungs
oder gegenrede je nachdem wie man will
jetzt vom stellvertretenden vorsitzenden
der spd fraktion sönke rix
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren zunächst an meine
vorrednerin natürlich hat auch die
letzte koalition was für studierende
getan da haben wir als spd schon für
aufgepasst
aber diese koalition die ampelkoalition
ist eine koalition des fortschritts und
eine koalition der modernisierung wir
haben uns zum ziel gemacht und werden
das auch mit diesem ersten schritt der
großen bafög-reform kollegen dies nur
der erste schritt auch wirklich den
ersten wird hier heute umsetzen wir
wollen menschen passende chancen geben
damit sie ihr leben lang tatsächlich den
aufstieg durch bildung erfahren können
wir kolleginnen und kollegen und das
unabhängig vom geldbeutel und deshalb
ist ziel dieser bafög-reform und dieses
ersten schritt auch dass mehr menschen
am ende vom bafög profitieren können und
das wird auch erreicht ihre kolleginnen
und kollegen
wie erreichen wir das zum beispiel durch
die erhöhung des freibetrags von eltern
meine damen und herren dadurch haben wir
tatsächlich die chance dass noch mehr
junge menschen noch unabhängiger noch
nicht unabhängig genug aber unabhängiger
tatsächlich vom einkommen der eltern vom
bafög profitieren können ein wichtiger
schritt um mehr menschen zu erreichen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und wir
erreichen es auch durch die anhebung der
altersgrenze auf 45 nicht nur mit dem
ziel dass mehr menschen davon
profitieren können sondern auch mit dem
hinweis darauf mit der mit dem angebot
daran nimmt das sind die das motto
lebenslanges lernen auch wirklich ernst
nutzt auch eure zweite und dritte chance
wir anstatt wir als gesellschaft wollen
dazu beitragen und du bekommst auch bis
zum 45 lebensjahr anspruch auf bafög das
ist eine gute sache liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und meine damen und herren wir schützen
auch das vermögen und vermögen hört sich
gross an als ob wir die dritte wohnung
finanzierung oder die millionen auf dem
konto irgendwie schützen wollen ein
vermögen ist das quasi klein ersparte
das was man von den eltern schon für die
lebensplanung mit auf den weg gebracht
hat was man sich im ersten teil quasi
seine ausbildung oder seines lebens
schon angespart hat wir sagen dieser
schutz soll noch größer werden und auch
dadurch ermöglichen wir den menschen
auch zu sagen okay ich nutze auch die
zweite oder dritte chance und auch etwas
später im höheren alter dass ich bereit
bin tatsächlich nochmal ein studium eine
ausbildung aufzunehmen dadurch mit
diesen drei beispiele genannten
schritten erreichen wir mehr menschen
und mehr menschen profitieren am ende
vom bafög liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und eine bessere förderung durch bafög
ist auch ein stück weit eine bekämpfung
des fachkräftemangels liebe kolleginnen
kollegen jeden cent den wir darin
investieren dass menschen eine
ausbildung machen dass menschen ein
studium beginnen können jede förderung
gebe dort machen es auch eine bekämpfung
des fachkräftemangels deshalb ist es
auch hier einen beitrag dazu liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen diskutieren
heute auch die ministerin hat es gesagt
den berufsbildungsbericht und ich bin
ihr sehr dankbar dass sie hier auch noch
einmal der gemeinsame haltung der
koalition deutlich gemacht hat dass die
akademische ausbildung und die
berufliche ausbildung für uns gleich
fertig sind das ist wichtig meine damen
und herren und dass es auch bleibt auch
weiter ziel dieser regierung und alle
maßnahmen die wir treffen klopfen wir
auch die gleichwertigkeit von
beruflicher und akademischer ausbildung
ab denn es ist eine komische
gesellschaftliche debatte dass man erst
den aufstieg dann erreicht wenn man ein
studium
beendet hat sondern sie haben's wenig
richtigerweise gesagt meister ist da
genauso viel wert wie ein master
bachelor nicht weniger nicht mehr wert
als ein gesellenbrief und daran halten
sie auch fest und wir machen das auch
deutlich in einer vorlage die uns heute
auch vorliegt nämlich zum notfall
mechanismus meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir reagieren
darauf auf die veränderte lage des ich
sag jetzt einmal nebenjob marktes ja
auch dazu beiträgt dass ich meine
ausbildung ein studium finanzieren kann
mit diesem notfall mechanismus erreichen
wir aber nicht nur studierende sondern
eben auch schülerinnen und schüler und
auch auszubildende die von
ausbildungshilfe abhängig sind und
dadurch machen wir noch einmal deutlich
für uns ist berufliche bildung und
akademische bildung gleich viel wertige
kollegen pflegt
und meine damen und herren wir können
diese gesamte debatte des bafögs nicht
unabhängig davon betrachten dass wir als
koalition uns noch eine weitere große
reform vorgenommen haben nämlich die
einführung der kindergrundsicherung und
in der kindergrundsicherung
auch hier unterstreichen wir noch mal
wir sind die koalition des fortschritts
und der modernisierung und vor allen
dingen auch des sozialen fortschritts
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der mit
der einführung
der kindergrundsicherung sichern werden
auch ab jungen menschen die sich in
ausbildung befinden egal ob in
beruflicher und akademischer ausbildung
auch hier wollen wir eine grundsicherung
dafür leisten bis zu einem gewissen
alter dass der staat die gesellschaft
auch dafür sorgt dass sich familien da
keine sorgen machen müssen wenn die
kinder wenn die junge menschen noch in
ausbildung sentiert sagen wir als
gesellschaft zu wie er sich an euch auch
das ab mit einer kindergrundsicherung
und wir freuen uns auch auf diese große
reform meine damen und herren
abschließend will ich sagen wir haben
alle in unserem programm stehen dass wir
mehr in bildung investieren sollen wir
haben alle in unserem programm stehen
dass wir jungen menschen mehr chancen
geben sollen wir als ampelkoalition
haben jetzt bewiesen mit diesem ersten
schritt der bafög-reform wir halten
unsere wahlversprechen herzlichen dank
sönke rix stellvertretender vorsitzender
der spd fraktion hat in seinem
redebeitrag hier in der debatte zum
bafög novelle auch erwähnt dass der
berufsbildungsbericht hiermit diskutiert
wird und es wird auch mitdiskutiert ein
antrag der afg die afg möchte das bafög
zu einer bürokratie arm und gerechten
sozialleistung für schüler und studenten
aus einkommensschwachen familien weiter
entwickeln so steht es über ihrem antrag
götz frömming dazu
ministerin sie sagten eben eingangs
ihrer rede dass sie sich freuen dass
dieses gesetz so schnell auf den weg
gebracht worden ist
bitte gestatten sie mir den hinweis das
merkt man dem gesetz auch an die kritik
des bundesrechnungshofs ist ja
umfangreicher als das gesetz selbst über
40 seiten ich weiß nicht ob sie das
gelesen haben da kann man gar nicht auf
alles eingehend heute meine damen und
herren in der tat das gesetz wurde nicht
nur schnell auf den weg gebracht sie
haben auch das bafög auf ein neues gleis
gesetzt aber meine damen und herren es
ist das falsche gleis die richtung
stimmt nicht und das eigentliche ziel
mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit zu schaffen
wird so nicht erreicht und ich will
begründen warum das so ist der
eigentliche sinn und zweck des bafögs
das war eigentlich bis vor kurzem noch
konsens in diesem hause war bisher das
bafög sollen junge leute bekommen die
sich ein studium sonst nicht leisten
können also für eine erstausbildung es
war im eigentlichen sinne eine
sozialleistung für einen begrenzten
kreis potenzieller empfänger das heißt
aber im umkehrschluss meine damen und
herren dass es eben auch menschen gibt
und geben muss die kein bafög bekommen
und dass die grenzen klar definiert sein
müssen studieren meine damen und herren
ist eine chance aber kein staatlich
garantiertes menschenrecht für jedermann
hier gesetz weicht diese einfache und
klare regeln nun auf das eigentliche
ziel ist offenbar ein komplett eine
komplett elternunabhängige förderung für
alle studenten und zwar egal woher sie
kommen egal wie alt sie sind ob sie
selbst oder ihre eltern vermögens sind
ist dann irgendwann auch egal zwar haben
sich dieses mal noch nicht getraut aufs
ganze zu gehen vielleicht hat auch herr
lindner noch mal mit blick auf den
haushalt interveniert aber die anheben
der altersgrenze auf 45 die linken
fordern ja sogar die komplette
abschaffung der altersgrenze die
stattliche anhebung der freibeträge und
so weiter zeigen doch wohin die reise
gehen sollen das hat übrigens auch die
anhörung der sachverständigen noch
einmal deutlich gemacht vollkommen zu
recht hat der verband der arbeitgeber
gesagt diese novelle und ich zitiere mit
ihrer erlaubnis frau präsidentin diese
novelle bedeutet nichts weniger als eine
abkehr vom bisherigen charakter des
bafög man könnte es auch deutlicher
sagen meine damen und herren sie
schaffen das bafög ab wir hingehen
wollen es erhalte
sie haben sie haben nicht verstanden
dass das bafög kein selbstzweck ist es
um das die zahl von mehr bafög
empfängern automatisch etwas gutes sie
haben auch nicht verstanden dass es kein
indiz für mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit ist
wenn möglichst viele und am ende alle
studenten bafög erhielten und sie haben
auch nicht verstanden das ist unsozial
ist wenn ein 35 jähriger knabe aus
wohlhabendem hause mit 45.000 euro auf
der hohen kante
transferleistung erhält die andere
vielleicht viel dringender bräuchte denn
die ausweitung des bafögs auf einen
immer größeren kreis von berechtigten
die hat natürlich auch ihren preis sie
können dann nämlich die bedarfssätze
nicht einmal an die derzeitige inflation
anpassen und deshalb meine damen und
herren bleibt ja auch der applaus ihrer
wählerklientel auf diese beim thema
waffen immer fielen auch aus die
koalition enttäuscht die jungen menschen
titelte gestern der spiegel mit den
ihnen vorliegenden neuen antrag der fdp
fraktion hingegen da gebe es all diese
probleme gar nicht da wir davon abstand
nehmen reichen älteren herren ein
studium zu finanzieren so wie sie das
machen wollen können wir den satz für
die wirklich bedürftigen menschen
erhöhen und zwar nicht um nur läppische
fünf bzw jetzt haben sie noch etwas
draufgelegt 5,75 prozent sondern sogar
um 17 prozent das würde dann bedeuten
dass wir einen schuss hätten von etwa
500 euro das wäre eine summe mit der man
auskommen könnte wohlgemerkt der kreis
der empfänger wäre geringer so dass wir
von der gesamtsumme im haushalt noch
lieben das meine damen und herren wäre
wirklich sozial gerecht und nicht das
gießkannenprinzip nachdem sie hier
verfahren wollen
meine damen und herren die weiteren
inhalte unseres antrags schauen sie sich
bitte nochmal an muss ich jetzt ein
bisschen überspringen auch wir sagen der
vermögensfreibetrag muss angehoben
werden aber bitte moderator lag
moderator er lag früher bei 8.200 euro
wir schlagen vor hin auf 8500 euro zu
erhöhen aber 45.000 euro das versteht
doch kein mensch warum man dann nicht
dieses geld nimmt um erst mal den
eigenen unterhalt zu finanzieren
natürlich muss das gesamte
antragsverfahren vereinfacht werden
haben sie recht wir brauchen auch
digitalisierung aber hier scheint ja die
absprache mit den ländern noch gar nicht
gelaufen zu werden die antwort auf eine
kleine anfrage hat uns gezeigt dass in
den meisten ländern noch nicht mal die
akten vorhanden sind und das personal
hier noch gar nicht vorbereitet und
geschult ist also auch hier muss
dringend noch nachgebessert werden meine
damen und herren lassen sie mich zum
abschluss nochmal auf die 28 novelle
eingehen die kommt er jetzt hier im
windschatten hinterher so noch schneller
wird die auf den weg gebracht wurde auch
nur so kurz erwähnt die ist jetzt nicht
so umfangreich aber die hat es in sich
und hier heißt es ich darf zitieren aus
dieser 28 novelle zitat die
bundesregierung wird ermächtigt durch
rechtsverordnung ohne zustimmung des
bundesrats im falle einer bundesweiten
notlage sie meinen wahrscheinlich
irgendwie eine weitere corona oder
ähnliche notlage das bafög vorübergehend
einen personenkreis zu öffnen der
normalerweise vom bafög bezug
ausgeschlossen ist meine damen und
herren kündigen sie hier eigentlich
schon den nächsten lockdown an obwohl
wir doch noch nicht einmal den ersten
evaluiert haben obwohl obwohl auch die
erste lok da uns wahrscheinlich gar
nichts gebracht haben in dieser hinsicht
haben sie denn haben sie denn er
jährigen so alt sind sie nicht aber
vielleicht kennen sie aus den
geschichtsbüchern doch was 1968 folgende
los war da gab es schon mal eine debatte
um notstandsgesetze oder standen sie nur
auf der anderen seite oder ihre
vorfahren auf der anderen seite der
barrikade da gab es eine art heute gibt
es eine andere art wo die hfg und ist
hier drin und die sagten meine damen und
herren das der falsche weg wir brauchen
keine notstandsgesetzgebung wir brauchen
keine ausschaltung der legislative
dieser bundestag hat in der pandemie
gezeigt dass er schnell reagieren kann
also verlassen sie diesen vater und
trugen kehren sie zurück zur
parlamentarischen demokratie
vielen dank
ganz frömming für die fdp und er spricht
von einer außerparlamentarischen
opposition im parlament ein
interessanter gedanke sie ich finde wir
haben ihnen eingeblendet meine damen und
herren ein kleines bild aus dem brüssel
wo heute der erste gipfel der erste rat
zusammentritt und wir rechnen mit einem
statement des bundeskanzlers und wenn
ich das bild richtig deutet jetzt auf
möglicherweise sogar auf dem weg zu
einer position wo er gleich zu in die
kameras und mikrofone sprechen wird wir
haben deshalb wie sie sehen
vorübergehend den bundestag verlassen
kommen gleich auch wieder zurück
interessante bilder die wir bekommen
gerade aus brüssel übrigens und ein
langer langer weg der bundeskanzler
abzuschreiten hat und schauen wir mal
was er sagt zum bevorstehenden eu rat
dem ja dann anschließend noch der g7
gipfel folgen wird und das nato
gipfeltreffen der kanzler
7 wenn sieben von zehn kindern aus
akademikerhaushalten ein studium
beginnen aber nur zwei von zehn aus
nicht akademiker haushalten und zeigt
dass einst formal gleiche
bildungschancen reichen nicht wir
brauchen real gleiche bildungschancen
und ja man kann sich natürlich auch mit
wenig geld irgendwie durchbeißen und
durch kämpfen aber müssen wir den jungen
menschen mit willen zu bildung und
ausbildung das leben wirklich so schwer
machen dürfen wir es uns als
gesellschaft leisten ist auch so viel
potenzial zu verzichten nur weil einige
nicht bereit sind gleiche
bildungszugänge für alle zu schaffen für
uns bündnisgrüne ist klar wir wollen
chancengerechtigkeit in der bildung und
dafür sind wir angetreten und davon
gehen wir jetzt an sparprogrammen und
darum haben wir nach jahren des
stillstands in einem cdu
bildungsministerium und frau staffler
das können sie jetzt auch einfach nicht
schön reden bleibt das ist die größte
reform seit 20 jahren im bafög also
nach jahren nach jahren des stillstandes
oder meinetwegen nach jahren von vielen
kleinen trippelschritten werden wir nun
in der ampel koalition die reform des
bafögs zu einem schwerpunkt machen und
gehen es wirklich an
diese reform erfolgten mehreren
schritten und wir machen heute den
anfang schon ab kommendem wintersemester
werden viel mehr menschen bafög bekommen
und ihre ausbildung ihr studium besser
finanzieren können der zweite schritt
ist ein nothilfe mechanismus der in
nationalen krisenfällen das bafög auch
für menschen öffnet die bislang keinen
zugang hatten das soll ein instrument
notwendig ist haben wir in der krise
gesehen und ziehen jetzt unsere schlüsse
drauf
und dann werden wir natürlich noch
einmal strukturell an zwar vergehen wir
wollen ein mechanismus für regelmäßige
bafög-erhöhung damit wir die leistungen
der wirklichkeit anpassen wir wollen
finanzielle planbarkeit für diejenigen
die ein studium aufnehmen wollen
einfachere schnellere
bearbeitungsverfahren realistische
anpassung der bürgermiliz dauer mehr
flexibilität und mehr unterstützung beim
beginn des studiums mit dem studieren
starthilfe so geht bildungsgerechtigkeit
das bafög wird den bundestag weiter dass
das steht meint des bundeskanzlers vor
dem europäischen rat der in kürze
beginnen wird folgt ja dann noch ein g 7
gipfel unter nato gipfel in der
kommenden woche wir sind zurück im
bundestag wo ist nach wie vor um die
novelle des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
geht aber auch um den bildungsbericht 20
22 und es geht auch um anträge der afg
haben wir eben schon gehört und es geht
um einen antrag der linksfraktion nicole
gohlke ist jetzt am pult sprecherin für
bildung und wissenschaft und außerdem
stellvertretende vorsitzende ihrer
fraktion
und bitte daran ist auch dass ein großer
teil dieser armut betroffenen
studierenden nämlich 45 studie sind die
bafög bekommen und das zeigt zweierlei
erstens nämlich dass das bafög längst
nicht alle erreicht die es bräuchte und
zweitens dass das bafög nicht
existenzsichernd nicht armutsfest ist
und das ist einfach ein skandal in einem
so reichen land gebracht
ich finde es unglaublich dass das so
lange zugelassen würde und unglaublich
ist aber auch dass auch die neue
ampelkoalition diesen missstand nicht
beseitigen wird denn das was diese 27
die novelle heute macht ist wieder ein
bisschen kosmetik an einem eigentlich
völlig heruntergewirtschafteten bafög
aber es heute die studie ist eben nicht
aus der armut das ist die situation und
das ist nicht akzeptabel
der neue bafög höchstsatz wird jetzt pi
mal daumen um die 930 euro sein davon
sollen die miete bezahlt werden die
energiekosten das essen die kleidung die
kranken die pflegeversicherung und auch
alle anderen aussagen die studie so
haben also laptop internet bücher kopien
semesterticket usw und jetzt wo ich das
so sage ich meine da merken sie es doch
selber da merken sie doch selber dass
das nicht geht dass diese rechnung
einfach nicht aufgehen kann in meiner
heimatstadt in münchen verschlingt die
miete über 80% des neuen bafög
höchstsatz es nicht des wohnkosten
zuschusses des höchstsatzes des neuen
höchstsatz in frankfurt sind es fast 60
es gibt fast keine hochschulstadt mehr
in der mann vom wohnkosten zuschuss im
bafög dient die miete bezahlen kann und
die inflation frisst die bafög-erhöhung
komplett auf da bleibt nichts übrig die
studis bleiben unter hartz-iv-niveau sie
bleiben unterhalb der armutsgrenze das
ist die situation und da wundert sich
dann die ampel warum wir nicht alle um
den hals fallen vor lauter dankbarkeit
und ich finde das wirklich ein bisschen
weltfremd das muss ich an dieser stelle
sagen
die linke stellt ihre vorschläge heute
ebenfalls zur abstimmung und sie könnten
ja sagen zu einer reform die die
studierenden tatsächlich aus der armut
holen ja dazu dass das geld endlich mal
reicht und dass es automatisch an die
inflationsrate angepasst wird und nicht
wie jetzt wo buchstäblich die
stimmungslagen zwischen
koalitionspartnern darüber entscheiden
ob studis mehr geld bekommen sie könnten
ja sagen zu einem mietkostenzuschuss der
tatsächlich die miete deckt weil er
nämlich regional gestattet ist denn die
miete in münchen oder in berlin ist eben
nun mal teurer als die in greifswald
oder in bamberg ja zu einer digital und
lärmen pauschale weil das gehört ja nun
mal auch zum studium dass man eben auch
arbeitsgerät braucht es könnte sich ja
nach den paar jahren auch irgendwann mal
rumgesprochen haben und sie könnten ja
sagen dazu dass sich studierende nicht
mehr fürs studium verschulden müssen
weil wir nämlich wissen dass vor allem
junge menschen aus einkommensarmen
familien und haushalten diejenigen sind
die wegen der angst vor verschuldung
daneben auf ein studium verzichten
zu alldem könnten sie ja sagen und das
sollten sie auch das wäre wirklich mal
ein schritt nach vorne
und und lassen sie mich noch ein wort
sagen zur 28 novelle die wir ja auch
heute beraten die pandemie hat uns in
der tat gezeigt dass die einrichtung
eines notfallmechanismus im bafög für
außergewöhnliche krisenlagen dringend
notwendig ist und es ist auch gut dass
die ampel das jetzt an geht aber der
vorschlag der parteien greift eben auch
hier zu kurz und hat noch einige lücken
zum einen ist es so dass weiterhin viele
studierende im falle einer krise leer
ausgehen würden rund 400.000
internationale studierende zum beispiel
werden bei den plänen der
bundesregierung ja überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt und die förderung in
notlagen sollte wirklich nicht an
regelschulen zeiten hängen ich meine das
ist doch wirklich komplett welt bringt
das in pandemie zeiten oder anderen
katastrophenlagen ausgerechnet
diejenigen regeln eingehalten werden
können die schon in normalzeiten völlig
an der lebensrealität der studierten
vorbeigehen ich hoffe jetzt einfach mal
dass sie bei dieser 28 novelle
vielleicht mal ein bisschen offener sind
für die anregungen aus der gesellschaft
aus den reihen der studierenden und auch
von den sachverständigen das wäre ein
echter fortschritt und vor allem wäre
das willen der studierenden vielen dank
nicole gohlke stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion und
sprecherin für bildung und wissenschaft
zum antrag ihrer fraktion zum bafög sie
sieht die jetzigen novelle die die
koalition hier einbringt und die heute
abschließend auch abgestimmt wird für
nicht existenz sichern und auch nicht
für krisenfest rea schröder ist am pult
bildungspolitische sprecherin der
fdp-fraktion
[Musik]
in der durch die pandemie bei vielen
familien die reserven aufgebraucht sind
in der durch den russischen
angriffskrieg unsere wirtschaft und
energieversorgung rechten in der die
inflation mit hohen preisen den menschen
zu schaffen macht in dieser
herausfordernden zeit ist die
bafög-reform ein lichtblick für
studierende sie kommt genau zur
richtigen zeit
und das war nur möglich weil die
ministerin dieses projekt zur top
priorität gemacht hat da war sie noch
keine zwei monate im amt und dafür dass
du die bafög-reform so schnell
vorantreibt liebe bettina danke ich dir
ganz herzlich
es macht einen unterschied wer im
ministerium sitzt mit der fdp hat die
unsägliche ignoranz gegenüber jungen
menschen endlich ein ende und ich kann
sie verstehen vorstellbar dass sie hier
direkt in die defensive gehen also fünf
reformen 16 jahren toll also wir
arbeiten im moment an dreien in der
letzten legislaturperiode haben sie eine
geschafft und den rest schuldenerlass
den sie damit eingeführt haben wir haben
sie ordentlich vergeigt wir führen jetzt
verbesserungen an der stelle ein und sie
redet zwar nicht davon aber das kann ich
auch verstehen dass sie von den 20 75
prozent die wir die freibeträge angeben
dass sie darüber gar nicht erst reden
weil das ist wirklich ein riesiger
batzen der genau dafür sorgt dass mehr
studierende wieder bafög erhalten und
zwar diejenigen die es ganz dringend
brauchen
generationengerechtigkeit das heißt für
uns liberale eine generation in den
blick zu nehmen die enkel die eltern und
auch die großeltern generation und
deswegen ist lebenslanges lernen für uns
ein herzensanliegen
studieren sind in deutschland zwar im
schnitt 23 jahre jung aber nicht jedes
leben verläuft nach dem motto abi
bachelor master berufseinstieg und daher
erhöhen wir mit der bafög novelle die
altersgrenze auf 45 jahren tragen
dadurch zickzack lebensläufen rechnung
wir wollen menschen ermutigen ihre
bildungsbiographie selbst zuschreiben
und ihnen neue kapitel hinzuzufügen und
zwar immer wieder
meine eltern sind nicht reich sie
verdient schon geld zu viel als dass
sich bafög erhalten könnte aber
unterstützen können sie mich nicht das
habe ich erst letzte woche wieder von
einem studenten gehört er wird durch die
beispiellose anhebung der
elternfreibeträge zum wintersemester das
erste mal bafög erhalten genau zur
richtigen zeit
die erhöhung von bedarf setzen und
wohnkosten zuschlägen ist eine wichtige
entlastung angesichts der hohen
inflation aber auch der bereits
beschlossene heizkostenzuschuss in höhe
von 230 euro den dank unserer ministerin
auch bafög empfängerinnen und bafög
empfänger erhalten der sorgt dafür dass
die wg zimmer in diesem winter nicht
kalt bleiben machen wir uns ehrlich auch
manche studierende die kein bafög
erhalten den bleiben im moment am ende
des monats manchmal nur dosen ravioli
dank der energie pauschale und durch die
erhöhung der minijob grenze von 450 auf
520 euro die ebenfalls zum
wintersemester kommt werden auch sie
spürbar entlastet
meine damen und herren liebe
studierende und wir werden weitermachen
und skizzieren daher in unserem
entschließungsantrag aus den
koalitionsfraktionen schon die nächsten
schritte denn unser ziel ist klar es
muss schluss sein damit dass das
elternhaus über bildungsweg und chancen
im leben bestimmt wir werden studis aus
bedarfsgemeinschaften eine studienstart
hilfe an die hand geben denn hat vier
darf kein bildungs killer sein wir gehen
das elternunabhängiges bafög an die
verlängern die förderungshöchstdauer
damit der kühlschrank kurz vor den
abschlussprüfungen nicht leer bleibt die
ampel ist angetreten und war für besser
zu machen damit das aufstiegsversprechen
der sozialen marktwirtschaft erneuert
wird heute gehen wir den ersten schritt
deswegen stimmen sie dem gesetzesentwurf
zu er ist sehr gut und er kommt genau
zur richtigen zeit
ist die perspektive von ria schröder der
bildungspolitischen sprecherin der
fdp-fraktion was er auch nachvollziehbar
ist mal einen koalitions gezänk wurf
dazu jetzt nadine schön aus der
unionsfraktion
sie ist stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende kollegen abi
looking for freedom
hakuna matata wie um die sorgen kümmern
wir uns morgen oder ganz kreativ ag 22
die schule war öfter dicht als wir mit
diesem abschnitt zwischen feiern auch
heute wieder viele schülerinnen und
schüler ihren abschluss ihr abitur ihr
fachabitur ihre möglichkeit ein studium
zu beginnen endlich geschafft der weg in
die zukunft steht ihnen offen und ich
will an der stelle
meine wirkliche hochachtung ausdrücken
vor dieser generation von
abiturientinnen und abiturienten die
wirklich in den letzten zwei jahren ganz
schwierige bedingungen hatten um sich
auf diese abschluss prüfungen
vorzubereiten
die schule
war wirklich öfter dicht und die plan
bedingungen man schwierig und deshalb
einen herzlichen glückwunsch und eine
große hochachtung vor dieser leistungen
alle schülerinnen und schüler an die
fachabitur ihren fach- abiturienten und
an die abiturientinnen und abiturienten
und auch die eltern die familien die das
alles mit begleitet haben mit diesem
mit diesem schritt ist viel freude und
hoffnung verbunden aber natürlich auch
so mancher banger blick wie geht es
weiter was soll ich jetzt machen macht
eine ausbildung mache ich ein studium
was sind die besten zukunftschancen für
mich und ich will an der stelle noch mal
sagen für uns als unionsfraktion ist
beides gleich viel wert die ausbildung
die berufliche karriere oder auch das
studium wir brauchen alle wir brauchen
facharbeiter wir brauchen gut
ausgebildete handwerker wir brauchen
akademiker und deshalb soll jeder junge
mensch in unserem land sich selbst
aussuchen können was er oder sie machen
will
mit dem wasser
schaffen wir haben wir das instrument
das man es sich wirklich aussuchen kann
das bafög ist mittlerweile über 50 jahre
alt es wird heute um es nochmal
klarzustellen zum 27 mal reformiert die
letzte bafög reform ist zum
wintersemester
2009/10 in kraft getreten ist wurde
fortlaufend reformiert fortlaufend
verbessert und es wurde nicht jahrelang
liegen gelassen wie man dass hier
versucht den eindruck zu erwecken
die reform die heute auf dem tisch liegt
hat für sehr viel enttäuschung gesorgt
bei den studentinnen und studenten
die höhe gleich die inflation nicht auch
aus die
zuverdienstmöglichkeiten sind nicht so
flexibel wie etwa beim minijob und das
antragsverfahren
bleibt lange und langsam bis man ein
bescheid hat kann es schon mal eine
ganze weile dauern
und deshalb ist diese form die wirklich
richtig ist die nächste reform dann
steht nämlich die 29 setzen werde und
für diese reform haben wir auch ganz
klare erwartungshaltungen wir wollen zum
einen dass die beantragten schnell und
einfach ist wir wollen zum zweiten dass
das bafög noch passgenauer ist wird uns
zum tippen dass es verlässlich ist zur
schnellen und einfachen beantragung
haben wir vorgelegt wir haben den
bafög-antrag in der letzten
legislaturperiode digitalisiert der
finanztest hat gerade vor kurzem die
verschiedenen antrags möglichkeiten sich
angeschaut und hat die staatliche lösung
explizit gelobt explizit empfohlen es
ist heute digital möglich einen bafög
antrag zu stellen entweder über das
statische portal oder auch über den sohn
von verschiedenen startup den zweiten
schritt gehen wir jetzt heute in dem wir
noch das schriftformerfordernis
abschaffen und der dritte schritt muss
aber dann auch sein dass die prozesse in
der verwaltung digitalisiert werden es
hilft ja nichts wenn ich digital den
antrag stellen kann und das dann ewig
dauert bis sich eine rückmeldung
bekommen wir haben mit dem register
modernisierungsgesetz die möglichkeit
geschaffen dass sich der behörde erlaube
auf andere daten zuzugreifen die eben
auch schon in verschiedenen behörden
liegen das ermöglicht eine schnelle
beantragen und die zukunft muss sein
dass ich in mir in der studentenzeit ein
bier bestellen und wenn das bier da ist
ich weiß auch die strafe bekomme oder
nicht das muss das ziel sein da dann
müssen sie sich auch messen lassen als
fortschritts koalition und unsere
unterstützung haben sie dabei
nächste rednerin für die spd fraktion dr
lina setzen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen sehr geehrte damen
und herren junge menschen sehen sich
gerade in vielfältiger art und weise mit
herausforderungen und problemlagen
konfrontiert auf die sie kaum einfluss
nehmen kann das sind die immer noch
anhaltenden folgen der krise es sind die
massiven preissteigerungen folge des
ukraine kriegs das ist eine
beängstigende
außenpolitische lage die mit dem
angriffskrieg russlands außer unserer
als verständlich gesehene
friedensordnung außer kraft gesetzt hat
und deswegen ist es gerade jetzt ein
umso wichtigeres zeichen dieser neuen
regierung für junge menschen noch
beginnt zur registratur periode eine
erste deutliche verbesserung im waffe
voranzubringen die noch in diesem jahr
im spätsommer in kraft treten wird wir
haben das bafög in unserer
prioritätenliste ganz weit oben gesetzt
nach oben gesetzt um jungen mit zu
menschen zu zeigen dass wir an ihrer
seite stehen dass wir uns ihre sorgen
annehmen dass wir sie nicht im regen
legen lassen dass wir für sie gute
politik machen und
was wir heute hier diskutieren ist ein
ganzes reformpakets
erstes öffnen wir mit der heute zu
beschließenden 27 novelle des bafög für
viel mehr junge menschen in ausbildung
stellen uns damit dem trend entgegen
dass die beziehungen zahlen immer weiter
nach zurückzusetzen wir setzen die
freibetragsgrenze deutlich nach oben um
20,75 prozent eine so deutliche erhöhung
habe ich ihn in diesen 16 jahren nicht
gesehen wir setzen auch die altersgrenze
deutlich nach oben wir bauen
eu-kritische hürden deutlich ab in dem
das antragsverfahren vereinfacht und
digitalisiert wird und wir sorgen auch
dafür dass diejenigen die bereits bafög
beziehen auch mehr davon haben deswegen
freue ich mich dass im parlamentarischen
verfahren es gelungen ist trotz der
angespannten haushaltslage hier nochmal
das bafög weiter zu erhöhen der bafög
höchstsatz steigt nun deutlich das ist
ein deutliches zeichen an euch liebe
studierende liebe auszubildende wir
sehen eure schwierige situation und wir
lassen euch damit nicht im stich
aber damit ist es natürlich nicht getan
das breit beraten wir heute zweiter die
nothilfe mechanismus die sogenannte
achten
naja
studierende ihr studium mit nebenjobs in
der gastronomie das war nie ein problem
des corona kann dann sind hotels kneipen
restaurants lange geschlossen worden und
plötzlich wussten viele nicht mehr wie
sie es jetzt eigentlich finanziell
weitergeht damit dass künftig nicht mehr
passieren kann verankern wir im bafög
einen krisenfesten zuverlässigen
unbürokratischen mechanismus studierende
dürfen dürfen nämlich hier auch in
dieser situation nicht im regen stehen
gelassen werden
sie sehen liebe kolleginnen kollegen die
ampel wird nur wenige monate nach
regierungsbeginn setzen wir bereits
erste langjährige bildungspolitische
forderungen
und trotzdem muss man natürlich sagen
dass diese schritte allein keine
nachhaltige transformation keine
nachhaltige trendwende im bafög bewirken
kommen und deshalb verständigen wir uns
heute mit dem von spd bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp vorgelegten
entschließungsantrag nochmal auf eine
große nachhaltige reform struktur reform
des bafögs dass waffen jahrelang nicht
angegangen werden konnte wird jetzt
angegangen und auch das beschließen wir
heute das sind zum einen natürlich
sachen wie die anhebung des voerder
restore die einführung einer studien
starter edition unterstützung von
studierenden aus bedarfsgemeinschaften
der elternunabhängige garantiebetrag
auch die absenkung des darlehens an
teils ganz viele weitere änderungen all
diese strukturellen punkte all diesen
strukturellen reformen die ja immer
wieder in den letzten jahren und jetzt
an uns herangetragen werden die werden
wir noch in dieser
legislaturperiode verabschieden und es
auch dringend notwendig und da möchte
ich auch gerne noch mal was zu den
bedarfssätzen sagen weil wir die debatte
natürlich immer wieder führen es braucht
hier endlich ein mechanismus zur
regelmäßigen anpassung und auch das
werden wir in der großen strukturreform
an
liebe verlegen legen sie sehen die ampel
koalition nimmt die bedürfnisse junger
menschen ernst wir machen was diese
ersten heutigen beschlüsse sind nur der
anfang wir haben ein großes paket vor da
gehen wir die ersten schritte zu einer
nachhaltigen verbesserung der
ausbildungsförderung und deswegen bitte
ich sie sie haben es ja gerade gesagt
schön das ist ein guter anfang dann
stimmen sie doch mit weil das ist ein
richtig gutes gesetz vielen dank
li na sei das für die spd fraktion die
noch mal geworben hat für die 27 novelle
des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
und laura kraft für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen ist die nächste rednerin
ich freue mich dass ich heute hier zu
bafög reden darf denn wir stoßen hier
heute eine reform an bei der wir den
kurs der letzten jahre korrigieren denn
bafög soll und muss wieder zu dem werden
als das einst gedacht war nämlich ein
echtes instrument der chancengleichheit
und was die hier kritisieren von der
union das hätten sie in den letzten
jahren alles schon bringen können also
sie hatten ja genug zeit
denn wenn bafög dar ankommt wo es
gebraucht wird dann kann das ausbildungs
biografien prägen auf arbeiterkindern
akademiker innen machen chancen eröffnen
und ermutigen und was wir jetzt brauchen
das sind echte verbesserungen für
studierende und das bringen
mit diesem gesetz
durch die anhebung der freibeträge um 20
75 prozent ermöglichen wir mehr menschen
ein studium zu beginnen und damit auch
die ausbildung zu beginnen die zu ihren
talenten und zu ihren zielen passt wir
heben die freibeträge in einem schritt
um mehr an als die gruppe und den
letzten vier jahren an aufschwung
gebracht hat die lebensrealität der
studierenden die muss sich endlich auch
in der grundlage für die bestimmung der
förderbeträge widerspiegeln und deshalb
erhöhen wir auch die bedarfssätze und
die wohnkosten pauschale weiter hinzu
kommen die kinderbetreuung zuschläge und
die krankenversicherungs zuschläge und
weil eben die derzeitige situation für
studierende so schwierig ist da haben
wir auch als ampelkoalition aus dem
parlament heraus per änderungsantrag
noch eine weitere erhöhung der
bedarfssätze und eben der freibeträge
auf den weg gebracht und damit wir auch
wirklich in zukunft regelmäßig die
bedarfssätze und freibeträge erhöhen da
haben wir auch das ministerium
aufgefordert ein verfahren der
kontinuierlichen anpassung zu etablieren
und natürlich kann das nicht alles sein
aber es ist ein erster schritt auf dem
richtigen weg und wir haben die
einführung eines verfahrens vereinbar
das dafür sorgt dass regelmäßig
bedarfsorientiert und zuverlässig
weitere erhöhung von den bedarfssätzen
und den freibeträgen kommen und wenn die
kosten kontinuierlich steigen ja dann
muss auch das bafög kontinuierlich
steigen
wir müssen uns auch auf die krisen der
zukunft vorbereiten und das machen wir
mit dem nothilfe mechanismus im bafög
und uns grünen ist dabei sehr wichtig
noch einmal zu betonen bei der nothilfe
geht auch bafög nach den regeln des
bafög also wenigstens die ersten sechs
monate der nothilfe zahlungen sollen
auch für die betroffenen zur hälfte als
zuschuss erfolgen das ist ganz wichtig
und egal welche krisen in zukunft kommen
weil das können wir jetzt noch nicht
absehen wir lassen die studierenden
nicht im regen steht wir schaffen ein
netz das sie auffängt
mit dieser novelle machen wir den ersten
schritt und die nächsten schritte der
reform die stehen auch schon vor der tür
und ja wir machen mit dem bafög ein
schritt in richtung zukunft und darauf
freue ich mich vielen dank
[Applaus]
laura kraft für die fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen und ihr wird jetzt folgen aus
der unionsfraktion getan
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ohne bafög wäre ich heute wohl nicht
abgeordnete ein weg wäre anders
verlaufen denn meine eltern haben mir
kein studium finanzieren können deshalb
war bafög für mich persönlich das tor
zur welt und so geht es millionen
anderen bafög hat uns ausbildung
ermöglicht unabhängig vom geldbeutel der
eltern
besteht damit für ausstieg und eine
erfolgsgeschichte für unser land denn
wir haben keinen anderen rohstoff als
bildung und deshalb ist jeder euro darin
bestens investiert
was
bedeutet für mich freiheit
bedeutet chancen deshalb haben mich auch
manche beiträge in dieser debatte auch
der heutigen wirklich befremdet die
ampel zeichnet ein verbot der
vergangenheit es sei nichts passiert
diese aussage ist falsch noch einmal zum
mitschreiben
wir haben das bafög erhöht 282 10 216 2
19 220 die haben das wohngeld erhöht um
30 prozent statt jetzt nur zehn prozent
es gebe viele andere sätze noch zu sagen
aber liebe frau kollegin star sie sind
hier die speerspitze gerade gewesen zu
sagen es ist nichts passiert sie haben
21 jahre lang mit regiert als spd sie
haben den bundesfinanzminister gestellt
die ist jetzt kleinzureden zeugt
entweder von amnesie oder politischer
schizophrenie
eigenartig sind die beiträge von fdp und
grünen die sich für ein auftakt in eine
jahrhundertreform feiern der aktuelle
spiegel bringt es auf den punkt ich
zitiere koalition liegt beim bafög nach
und enttäuscht die jungen menschen denn
die geplante erhöhung zum ersten august
verpufft der zuschuss von 5
75 prozent
kompensiert noch nicht einmal die
preissteigerung sehen sie sich die
inflationsrate an 8,9 prozent und sie
wagen es jetzt hier von einer
jahrhundertreform zu sprechen das ist
erbärmlich
foto lehmann gestatten sie eine
zwischenfrage von kai gehring aus der
fraktion die grünen berge ein
ausschussvorsitzenden immer sie haben
das wort
ich freue mich sehr dass auch sie das
bafög wichtig und bedeutsam finden
konnte man jetzt aber in den 16 jahren
schwarz geführter cdu
bildungsministerien nicht besonders
bemerken jetzt habe wollte ich fragen
nachdem sie jetzt so massiv angreifen
angreifen die bafög-novelle dieser
ampelkoalition sie zur kenntnis genommen
haben dass nach 16 jahren unions
regierung
89% kein bafög mehr erhalten und das
bafög in einem historischen tiefstand
war und jetzt eine neue regierung da ist
und jetzt erstmal die größte reform seit
20 jahren macht und noch zwei weitere
vor hat in dieser wahlperiode
das heißt das ist nachholende
modernisierung und aktive gerechtigkeits
politik weil 89% kein bafög mehr
bekommen haben dass es ihre
regierungsbilanz jetzt geht's richtig
rund und wir haben den bafög turbo
gezündet und ich wollte fragen ob sie
das zur kenntnis genommen
lieber herr kollege gehring ich kann nur
zur kenntnis nehmen was realität ist was
sie erzählt haben ist ein ist ein großes
gespinst denn eines erleben wir heute
nicht eine jahrhundertreform
die tatsache allein dass sie sich feiern
lassen wollen für eine erhöhung der
sätze um 5,75 prozent die aufgefressen
will aufgefressen wird von der inflation
und die weit hinter dem zurückbleibt was
wir allein 2009 10 in der großen
koalition machen heißt doch dass sie
tatsächlich die realität verein und ich
würde sie deshalb geht schauen sie sich
an was passiert ist gerne im juli 2009
10 haben wir unter damals mit unserer
ministerin anja karliczek das 26 war
veränderungs gesetz in kraft getreten
wir haben die bedarfssätze gesteigert
wir haben die wahl für kranken verpflegt
wird wir haben war für kranken- und
pflegeversicherungsbeiträge eingeführt
es geht nicht um glauben lesen sie doch
einfach mal schauen sie sich daten und
fakten an
die kleine fakten leugnung bringt sie
hier nicht weiter und das ergebnis kleid
nichts jahrhundertreform sie sind mit
dieser reform als tiger gestartet und
als bettvorleger gelandet
[Applaus]
bedarf
bedarfsgerecht gibt zum beispiel auch
anders wenn man den unterpunkt zu bedarf
sehen wie zuschläge und real mittel
liegen die zwei diametral auseinander
die wohnungs pauschale bleibt immer noch
50 euro unter den durchschnittlichen
mietkosten jetzt reden wir nicht über
ein wg zimmer in münchen in frankfurt
oder wie auch immer wo ich allein für
ein zimmer 600 700 euro zahle an dieser
realität gehen sie mit ihrer reform
komplett so meine damen und herren
verlassen ein weiteres mal den bundestag
vorübergehend zu robert habeck der im
bundeswirtschaftsminister mit neuen
informationen zur energieversorgung im
land
haben sie einfach vom tisch gewischt was
die minijobs ermöglicht haben versagen
sie jetzt den studierenden dabei wird es
unmittelbar den studierenden helfen
übrigens auch den betrieben jede
arbeitskraft wird gebraucht die
studenten die sich engagieren sollten
auch den eindruck haben dass leistung
sich lohnt aber dazu von ihnen kein wort
im gegenteil unseren antrag legen sie ab
und wie gesagt die ankündigung der
reform von der sie sprechen darauf
warten wir noch und dabei hätten sie
jetzt die ersten weichen stellen können
und auch müssen das gilt insbesondere
für die voerder höchstdauer es braucht
dafür zwingend eine evaluation
daten damit man sieht ob und inwiefern
muss gott erhöht werden denn zurzeit ist
das größte problem für studentinnen und
studenten
dass die regelstudienzeiten in den
allermeisten studiengängen nicht zu
schaffen sind auf unseren antrag auf
durchführung einer evaluation haben sie
abgelegt und vor diesem hintergrund ist
ihre reform das wort nicht wert mit dem
sie es bezeichnen sie ist zu wenig zu
spät und dem grunde nach zu geringen in
diesem sinne werden wir es ablehnen
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
jessica rosenthal
[Applaus]
liebe sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
kollegin frau connemann vielleicht sage
ich das einfach mal ganz deutlich für
die spd-fraktion bei uns kann man auch
mitglied sein soll man sogar mitglied
sein und im herzen dieser demokratie
sein wenn man eine ausbildung gemacht
hat es braucht kein studium um hier
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages zu
sein das geht wie die spd fraktion
und eigentlich auch für sie deshalb
möchte ich die ab auszubildenden und die
berufliche bildung in das zentrum dieser
debatte hier rücken wir beraten heute
nämlich nicht nur die bafög-reform die
natürlich auch positive auswirkungen auf
die berufs auf die berufsbildungs
beihilfe hat ab sondern wir beraten auch
den berufsbildungsbericht und genau über
den müssen wir hier auch sprechen denn
er zeigt zum ersten was wir geschafft
haben und mit wir meine ich die politik
ich meine den ausbildungs
rettungsschwimmen den wir auf den weg
gebracht haben für den wir als spd
gekämpft haben aber ich meine damit auch
die unternehmerinnen und unternehmer ich
meine damit alle akteurinnen und akteure
in der beruflichen bildung und ich meine
damit vor allem ganz besonders die
auszubildende denn wenn wir uns den
berufsbildungsbericht angucken sehen wir
es gab stabile ausbildungs verläufe das
ist gut das hätten wir nicht erwartet in
der korona pandemie es gab ein rückgang
der vertragslose quote dass es auch sehr
gut und es gab erfolgreiche prüfungen
über 90% herzlichen glückwunsch an alle
azubis die das geschafft haben
aber der berufsbildungsbericht zeigt
natürlich auch was wir noch zu tun haben
wenn wir 63 1000 unbesetzte stellen
haben die 25.000 ungefähr unversorgten
bewerberinnen gegenüberstehen da müssen
wir sagen es gibt ein passus problem ja
und deshalb ist es umso wichtiger dass
wir jetzt alles dafür tun die
berufsorientierung zu stärken mit allen
akteurinnen und akteuren die dazu
gehören es muss uns nämlich besorgen
wenn die 15 prozent weniger junge
menschen zur berufsberatung gegangen
sind und deshalb braucht es jetzt eine
kraftanstrengung es braucht aber auch
politischen willen nicht nur die
berufliche bildung zu stärken sondern
auch zu systematisieren endlich dafür zu
sorgen dass es nicht zu fall ist ob ich
einen ausbildungsplatz irgendwo bekommen
habe oder meine eltern mein ratschlag
gegeben haben sondern dass ich will
meine stärken und schwächen erfahren
kann dass ich wirklich mich auch
ausprobieren kann und es braucht eine
stärkung der jugend berufs agenturen
genau das haben wir uns vorgenommen als
ampelkoalition denn uns ist es nicht
egal dass 46.000 junge menschen einfach
verschwunden sind wir wissen nicht wo
die sind was zu machen die machen auf
jeden fall keine ausbildung und das darf
nicht sein wir brauchen beste beratung
in den jugend berufs agenturen und
natürlich müssen wir die ausbildungs
mobilität erhöhen dazu trägt die heutige
reform auch bei aber wir müssen noch
mehr tun es kann nicht sein dass man zum
beispiel eine ausbildung nicht anfangen
kann weil man die miete in der stadt
einfach nicht bezahlen kann oder wenn
man und das haben wir hier in pubs in
berlin hier schon viel gehört habe ich
in bonn viel gehört einfach keine
wohnung findet weil die wohnungen an
auszubildende nicht vergeben werden und
deshalb ja wir müssen auch in der
ausbildungs mobilität unbedingt viel tun
aber ich will auch klar sagen dass es
nicht nur ein passus problem es gibt
nicht nur ein passus problem sondern wir
sehen in der beruflichen bildung auch
dass es um gleiche chancen gibt wenn man
sich anguckt das bei den ungelernten
bei menschen mit zuwanderungsgeschichte
34,8 prozent sind also und ungelernte
menschen zuwanderungsgeschichte 34,8
prozent während es bei menschen die
keine zuwanderungsgeschichte sind haben
nur 89 und da muss man etwas sagen wir
haben ein diskriminierendes und ein
nicht chancen geben das
berufsbildungssystem und das ist nicht
in ordnung wenn der einwanderungsland
sein wollen was wir sein wollen müssen
wir da besser werden und dafür haben wir
1 elke punkten was wir auch einen
koalitionsvertrag beschreiben und das
ist die ausbildungsplatzgarantie diese
ausbildungsplatzgarantie zeigt und ist
eine chance für uns alle von staatlicher
seite ein upgrade zu geben der
beruflichen bildung einerseits beide
maßnahmen zusammen fassen weil wir
besser werden weil wir systematisieren
und es ist auch ein angebot an die
unternehmerische verantwortung an der
stelle mitzuwirken noch mal einen
richtigen boost für die berufliche
bildung zu geben und deshalb freue ich
mich darauf all diese projekte anzugehen
und vor allem der beruflichen bildung
dem platz zu geben den sie verdient
mitten ins herz der parlamente mitten
ins herz der fraktion vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen dr anja reinhardt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin liebe gäste ja wir reden
heute über das bafög und über den
berufsbildungsbericht und dann mehr
reden gerät damit reden wir über
studierende und azubis denn berufliche
und akademische bildung sind uns gleich
viel wert und man kann auch ohne studium
und bafög abgeordnete werden
und sind beide gruppen gleich viel wert
denn sie tragen gleichermaßen dazu bei
dem fachkräftemangel zu begegnen und an
dieser stelle unser herzlichen dank an
alle die einen beitrag leisten junge
menschen mit auf den weg zu bringen in
ihre berufliche entwicklung an alle
schulen lehrkräfte projektträger
natürlich an die eltern und dann alle
ausbildungsbetriebe und ja
wir wissen dass die letzten beiden jahre
hart werden das zeigen uns auch die
zahlen des berufsbildungsberichts und
wenn sie sich zwei zahlen marken sollten
dann bitte die 24.000 und die 63.000
denn sage und schreibe 24 1000
schülerinnen und schüler haben im
letzten jahr keinen ausbildungsplatz
bekommen und die 63.000 ist genau so
alarmierend denn 63.000
ausbildungsplätze konnten ja 21 nicht
besetzt werden und diese zahlen zeigen
deutlich dass wir ein problem gehabt
haben das liegt nicht nur an corona denn
die zahlen waren fordert nämlich auch
nicht viel besser
wir sind uns einig dass wir uns als
gesellschaft nicht leisten können auf
der einen seite den fachkräftemangel zu
beklagen und auf der anderen seite
schülerinnen und schüler ohne
ausbildungsplatz stehen zu lassen und es
ist offensichtlich dass wir ein besseres
matching brauchen zwischen azubis und
ausbildungsplätzen salopp gesagt jeder
topf braucht eine passenden deckel und
deswegen werden wir erstens gemeinsam
mit den ländern und den kommunen
berufsorientierungs angebote schaffen
denn mal ehrlich wie soll man denn aus
einem einwöchigen praktikum in der
neunten klasse entscheiden können
welchen beruf ich lerne
zweiter
judentums agenturen ausbauen und mehr
beratungsangebote und bringen denn wir
haben doch gerade in der pandemie gilt
sehen wir die zahl der bewerbungen sinkt
weil wir die schülerinnen nicht mehr
direkt erreichen konnten und drittens
werden wir in den regionen dienst zu
wenig ausbildungsplätze gibt jungen
menschen mit der ausbildungsgarantie
eine faire chance geben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen haben doch das
gemeinsame ziel mehr junge menschen
darin zu unterstützen ihren platz im
leben und im beruf zu finden wir
brauchen doch mehr menschen die eine
ausbildung machen im handwerk im
tourismus in der pflege im kampf gegen
die klimakrise und wirst du ins doch an
jeder stelle die züge haben verspätung
weil wir auf lokführerinnen bauen der
biergarten nebenan hat so weil da wird
kein personal bekommt kinder muss nach
hause geschickt worden weil die kitas
keine erzieherinnen finden
kurzum wir nehmen die ergebnisse des
berufsbildungsberichtes angst wir werden
das match so schnell wie möglich
verbessern mehr junge menschen für eine
ausbildung begeistern und so dem
fachkräftemangel begegnen
herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
stephan albani
[Applaus]
sie geht eine frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zwei seiten
einer medaille
andersartig aber gleichwertig die zwei
säulen auf denen unsere wirtschaft
stabil ruth all dies sind beschreibungen
für die berufliche und akademische
ausbildung die jeden tag von zahlreichen
menschen auf politik kam an schulen und
vielen anderen mehr und auch heute hier
gerne und häufig benutzt werden
insofern habe ich mich schon sehr
gewundert dass die ampel fraktionen die
debatte zum jährlichen
berufsbildungsbericht kurzerhand in der
debatte zum bafög novelle hat einfließen
nach dem verlauf der reden die beiden
letzten waren eine löbliche ausnahme
nach dem verlauf der rede muss man sagen
hat fast untergehen lassen uns war der
berufsbildungsbericht stets eine eigene
debatte wert
wir von der union haben den vergangenen
jahren die berufliche bildung durch das
berufsbildungs modernisierungsgesetz und
wesentliche verbesserung des
aufstiegsfortbildungsförderungsgesetz
gestärkt das sind die bisherigen
beiträge überwiegenden bafög beschäftigt
haben mögen wir die studierenden
verzeihen wenn jetzt zum einen die
kollegin staffler schön und konnte man
in vollem umfang zustimme und dann
weniger das gesagte wiederhole und
vielmehr mich um ausgleich bemühen vor
ministerin sie sprechen von ihrem haus
als dem chancen ministerium konkrete
vorschläge zur stärkung der beruflichen
bildung jenseits der ankündigung eines
exzellenzcluster wettbewerbes haben sie
bisher aber nicht gemacht und ich würde
mir wünschen da wir in der letzten
legislatur schon ein exzellenzwettbewerb
innovent heißt er auf den weg gebracht
haben dass ihr konkretes folgt aber
keine sorge wir helfen gerne und ich
weise darauf hin denn heute abend werden
wir in eine debatte weitere vorschläge
unterbreiten die sie gerne aufgreifen
können
was wir brauchen ist mindestens ein buch
für die berufliche bildung nach corona
und wenn das heute eine
jahrhundertreform ist dann erwarte ich
eine jahrtausend anstrengung auch der
ausbildungsmarkt leidet nämlich den zwei
letzten jahren von corona oder die
folgen der pandemie einblick in den
berufsbildungsbericht zeigt es uns die
zahl der ausbildungsverträge ist immer
noch deutlich unter dem vorkrisenniveau
minus 9,9 prozent im vergleich zu 2009
10 die zahl der ausbildungs anfänger und
anfängerinnen hat sich nur leicht um 1,3
prozent erhöht rückgänge zeigen dagegen
leider nur so zeigen sich leider nun
auch im schulischen ausbildungsgängen
die in den letzten jahren sogar gegen
den trend aufgewachsen sind nun gehen
sie zurück positiv ist jedoch zu
vermerken dass der das
ausbildungsangebot
auf 536.000 200 ausbildungsstellen
gewachsen ist und hier 63.000
unbesetzten stellen noch 24 suchende
24.000 suchende entsprechend gegenüber
stellen also passus probleme sind
weiterhin das thema hier braucht es
ideen und diese dinge anzugehen wir
fordern daher unter anderem eine
strukturierte und zielorientierte
berufsorientierung um junge menschen
passgenau und niederschwellig zu
erreichen es braucht dazu individuelle
auf den einzelnen zugeschnittene pläne
für schnuppertage und praktika nicht
getrennt voneinander absolvierte
maßnahmen die mehr an der verfügbarkeit
als an den talenten der suchenden
orientiert sind die bundesregierung
könnte dabei übrigens auch auf die
anstrengungen aus dem letzten sommer
zurückgreifen dem sommer der ausbildung
aufbauen und diese weiter verfolgen aber
auch das wird streichen aber für
weiteres reicht heute leider meine
redezeit in dieser debatte nicht so viel
also zum frühstück mehr berufliche
bildung zum abend um 18 uhr 30
herzlichen dank
stephan albani war das für die
fraktionen cdu/csu es geht hier nach wie
vor um das berufs- und
jetzt wird auch noch mal auf der
ehrentribüne begrüßt preisträgerin und
sonderbotschafterin der vereinten
nationen navi am ural
sehr geehrte frau morath ihnen gelangen
die flucht aus der gefangenschaft des
sogenannten islamischen staates seitdem
berichten sie der welt von ihrem
schicksal dem schicksal ihrer familie
und dem des jesidischen volkes sie haben
eine humanitäre organisation gegründet
die sich für die opfer sexueller gewalt
in konflikten engagiert immer wieder
werden vergewaltigungen gezielt einem
jahr besonders perfide waffe gegen die
zivilbevölkerung auch in russischen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine die
staatengemeinschaft darf diese
verbrechen nicht hinnehmen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau morath deswegen vielen
dank für ihren einsatz für die rechte
von frauen weltweit und herzlich
willkommen im deutschen bundestag wir
freuen uns dass sie hier sind
anerkennende worte der bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas für nadia murat
jesiden die sich für ihr volk einsetzt
dass immer wieder verfolgt worden ist in
der vergangenheit aber auch in jüngster
zeit durch den islamischen staat wir
sind bei der vorletzten rednerin
angekommen in der debatte über das
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetz
beziehungsweise dessen novelle und wir
hören und sehen carolin wagner aus der
spd fraktion
wenn wir über ein gutes leben nachdenken
und wer wie wir als spd den anspruch hat
ein gutes leben für die vielen millionen
menschen in diesem land zu schaffen und
nicht nur für diejenigen die viele
millionen haben dann muss man
unweigerlich über bildungschancen
nachdenken und ziehen den blick nehmen
mit blick auf das studium zeigt sich
hier akuter handlungsbedarf viel zu
lange wurde das bafög als das zentrale
instrument zur förderung von
bildungsgerechtigkeit zum abbau von
bildungs schranken und der 16 jahren
unions geführten bildungsministerium
vernachlässigt und werte frau kollegin
staffler das sind keine fans news
sondern die realität und die nackten
zahlen sprechen für sich 20 20 erhielten
27 prozent weniger menschen bafög als
noch 1991 und aktuell sind es noch elf
prozent der studierenden
11% das chancen instrument bafög haben
sie regelrecht verkümmern lassen und
daran haben auch fünf novell nichts
geändert und auch in sachen anpassung
des bafögs an die neue realität diverser
bildungsbiographien wurde in der
regierungszeit der union die so vieles
einfach ausgesessen die vsg
liebe kollegen wagner gestatten sie an
der zwischenfrage oder bemerkung von der
kollegin
staffler aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
sie haben das wort besten dank sie haben
es jetzt gerade nochmal nochmals sowie
in der letzten sekunde auch schon gesagt
deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
etwas zitieren chancengleichheit hat
großes gewicht in dieser koalition und
wir passen das bafög regelmäßig an nach
der erhöhung in 2 17 erhöhen wir das
bafög gibt zwei 19 und werden es 220
noch einmal erhöhen das zeigt das bafög
wird verlässlich auf bambara das ist ein
erfolg der sich in regelmäßigkeit
fortsetzt das ist ein konkreter beitrag
zur chancengleichheit ein zitat ihres ag
vorsitzenden der hier auch da sitzt zur
letzten bafög-novelle sie behaupten
jetzt hier das wäre alles mist gewesen
ist dass ihr verständnis contra stellte
er von verlässlicher politik für die
studentinnen und studenten in diesem
land
liebe freundschaft die sache ist doch
die man sollte politik machen und man
sollte sie immer wieder an der realität
entsprechend anlegen und wenn ich mir
diese zahlen anschaut mit 11 prozent
dann zeigt sich einfach dass hier
stärkere akuter handlungsbedarf ist und
den setzen wir jetzt um mit dem ersten
schritt gehen wir jetzt heute vorlegen
und mit dem zweiten schritt der in den
nächsten jahren auf jeden fall holt weil
wir eben wissen dass wir die einzige
ressource in diesem land die vielen
klugen köpfe fördern müssen ganz einfach
genau das gegenteil wie es eben schon
gesagt habe macht jetzt die spd-geführte
zukunft koalition der ampel mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzesnovelle werte damen
und herren und wir feiern uns dafür
nicht selbst liebe frau connemann zu
einem wir machen schlicht und ergreifend
unsere arbeit nicht mehr nicht weniger
mit der aktuellen bafög reform legen wir
rasch den hebel um damit mehr junge
menschen studieren können auch wenn die
eltern dies eben finanziell nicht
unterstützen können und wie unmittelbar
daran zukunftschancen junger menschen
hängen das weiß ich aus 13 jahren
berufserfahrungen als studienberaterin
in einem meiner letzten
beratungsgespräche im sommersemester 20
21 berichtete mir ein student dass er
einen ablehnungsbescheid vom bafög-amt
erhalten hatte das einkommen seiner
eltern er busfahrer sie verkäuferin im
einzelhandel lag knapp über dem eltern
freibetrag und für diesen junge mann
stand das studium somit plötzlich auf
der kippe mehr nebenher arbeiten konnte
er nicht mehr die eltern gaben schon das
was ihnen möglich war und genau an
dieser stelle setzen wir jetzt an wir
heben die freibeträge ganz massiv um 20
prozent und so bringen wir mehr menschen
mehr junge menschen in ein studium wir
haben die altersgrenze von 34 auf
künftig 45 jahre und bringen damit mehr
mittel junge menschen in ein studium und
genau das entspricht auch der heutigen
realität diverser bildungswege die eben
auch erst später nach einer ersten
beruflichen phase oder nach einer
familien gründungsphase zu einem studium
führen dass
werte damen und herren ist der erste
schritt um das bafög zukunftsfähig zu
machen der erste schritt der jetzt
schnell gegangen werden kann und muss
nämlich schon zum kommenden
wintersemester und dem wir auch
tatsächlich gehen und das ist der
unterschied wir bringen jetzt erst mal
mehr studierende ins system hinein und
das ist gut so liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die zukunft koalition wäre aber
nicht die zukunfts koalition wenn sie
nicht jetzt schon wisse dass weitere
schritte folgen werden und folgen müssen
im nächsten jahr werden wir die weiteren
aspekte die im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten sind umsetzen darauf freue
ich mich schon heute und für das
kommende wintersemester rufe ich alle
studierenden auf prüfen sie für sich ob
sie mit den neuen vorgaben vielleicht
antragsberechtigt werden und bafög
beziehen können und somit erleichtert
ihr studium fortsetzen können und allen
studieninteressierten empfehle ich
ebenfalls sich zum bafög zu informieren
und bei bedarf einen antrag zu stellen
denn das bafög bietet eine hervorragende
finanzierungsgrundlage für ihr studium
vielen herzlichen
caroline wagner aus der spd fraktion und
ich habe schon am anfang gesagt
vorletzte reden durfte etwas länger
machen weil gitta connemann noch eine
zwischenfrage hat beim letzten reden an
bruno hügel fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen sie haben es von meiner
vorrednerin gehört wir haben uns als
koalition vorgenommen das bafög
signifikant zu stärken in dieser
legislaturperiode und für mehr
bildungsgerechtigkeit zu wurden neun
monate nach der wahl liegt nun das liegt
ihnen nun das entsprechende bafög
änderungsgesetz samt
entschließungsantrag vor so erhöhen wir
signifikant die bedarfssätze und
freibeträge und wir machen das bafög
unbürokratischer und flexibler die
zusammenfassung ist die ampel koalition
steht zu ihrem wort
und liebe kolleginnen dafür stellen wir
sondern 22er haushalt 193 millionen euro
zusätzlich bereit und wir werden in den
nächsten jahren ca 2 milliarden euro
mehr auf den weg bringen für chancen
gerechte bildung und für sorgenfreies
studieren unser leitsatz ist und bleibt
der zugang zu bildung darf eben nicht
vom geldbeutel der eltern abhängen und
ja die inflation belastet die menschen
sehr gerade auch studierenden das ist
auch das resultat einer verfehlten
energie und geopolitik in den letzten
jahren aber und das ist das
entscheidende das können wir eben jetzt
nicht mit einer einzigen bafög-reform
auffang deswegen entlastende gezielt
auch studierende und azubis indem wir
zum beispiel den boden zuschlag um elf
prozent erhöhen oder den
heizkostenzuschuss auf 230 euro
verdoppelt haben das schafft sicherheit
und vertrauen in zeiten multipler krisen
und dass sie das konsistent versuchen
kleinzureden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union bei
gleichzeitigen total versagen und 16
jahren bildungsministerin das sagt mehr
über sie aus als über uns liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und jetzt höre
ich zum wiederholten male auch in dieser
debatte dass wir viel zu wenig geld wird
das fahrzeug zur verfügung stellt viel
zu wenig machen aber liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir werden in den nächsten
jahren ich habe es gesagt zwei
milliarden euro zusätzlich zur verfügung
stellen und da frage ich mich als
haushälter schon was haben sie denn
eigentlich von bezug zum geld also zwei
milliarden euro das ist doch kein platz
das ist doch keine peanuts mein eindruck
ist dass sie den bezug zur
fiskalpolitischen realität
2022 völlig verloren haben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
und 1 doch es wurde auch schon
angesprochen in den vergangenen zehn
jahren ist die zahl an bafög-empfänger
einen kontinuierlich zurückgegangen es
ist ihnen nicht gelungen diesen trend
aufzuhalten es ist ihm ebenfalls nicht
gelungen das bafög zu entbürokratisieren
zu flexibilisieren beziehungsweise
überhaupt an den tatsächlichen bedarf
anzupassen
wir stehen jetzt hier als ampelkoalition
entgegen und es wird höchste zeit liebe
kollegin kollegen herzlichen dank
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur änderung des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
der ausschuss für bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
empfiehlt unter buchstabe a seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
2399 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf drucksachen
1631 und
2244 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das anzeichen
dass sind die fraktion die linke spd
bündnis 90 grüne fdp
wer stimmt dagegen das ist die cdu csu
fraktion und die fdp fraktion
enthaltungen sehe ich nicht der
gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung angenommen
[Applaus]
noch nicht ganz also die dritte beratung
und schlussabstimmung kommt jetzt ich
bitte diejenigen die dem gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen sich zu erheben
das ist die fraktion die linke spd
bündnis 90 grünen und die fdp fraktion
wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die cdu csu fraktion und die afg
fraktion enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht damit ist der
gesetzentwurf
angenommen
großer applaus jetzt aus dem rhein der
ampelkoalition
dass die 27 die änderung des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
hier eine mehrheit gefunden hat übrigens
auch mit den stimmen der linksfraktion
der das war nicht weit genug geht aber
die diesen gesetzentwurf auf dem
richtigen weg sieht kommen wir in
zeitnot wir haben noch weitere
abstimmung heute